hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the key
themes that Rainer Maria Rilke stressed
is over and over again in his letters to
a young poet is not something that is
just applicable to younger people those
were in childhood or adolescents young
adulthood it really is for all of us it
spans the entire time of our lives up
into the very end and that is that we
need to develop patience that some
things can in fact be forced or ordered
or compelled to appear at this
particular time think about your
calendar for example there's some things
that you can put on the calendar you can
arrange that this will happen at this
time but when it comes to so many other
things in our life particularly those
things that matter the most they don't
work on a timetable even those things
that that matter perhaps a bit less and
can be broken down into discrete tasks
they almost invariably take longer thank
you a lot for them as you're scheduling
them and when it comes to things like
love or emotions or understanding what
it is to be a human being there there
isn't any schedule on which you
can work these things out you can't
break them down into subtasks with
benchmarks and put them into software to
track your task management or anything
like that as a matter of fact that would
be antithetical to doing something along
those lines so you know what is really
important to us the development of a
friendship for example the understanding
of a philosophical concept it can't be
forced it takes its own time there are
ideas that I'll just talk about my own
experience and I'll talk about that of
my students there are ideas in
existentialist thought that I thought
that I fully understood back when I was
in my teens or my 20s and it was only in
my 40s that I realized what the author
was actually talking about and how
superficial and off-base my
understanding had been and how to get
myself from that point over to where the
author was was going and what sort of
journey I might need to take along the
way that that's the sort of thing that
you can't just get a recipe book for or
a set of algorithms or you know a
bullet-pointed set of you know bits of
advice write some listicle or life hacks
or anything like that there's a matter
of fact you could say that anything
important really can't be turned into a
life hack and making a life hack out of
it and adopting that life heck mentality
is probably going to stand in the way
many of my students in the 20 years that
I've been teaching have talked to me
about you know what they understood of a
concept or an experience or a
distinction really on in studying it and
then what they really understood it to
be much later on sometimes they email me
long after that they've finished their
official academic studies and say I
finally get what this point in ethics
was so we really have to have patience
we need to exercise a sort of attitude
awaiting or carrying out a vigil not
just a you know putting it to the side
and saying all right
Oh that'll take care of itself I'll
think about that later but being open
being receptive waiting for something to
blossom to unfold to grow into what it
is that it's supposed to be within
ourselves within our own minds and
experience and there's there's quite a
few places in the letters where where
there's some really interesting advice
that's being given in in the third
letter he talks about judgments and I
think this is a very important point
that many people particularly in
philosophy and in other fields often
miss what do we mean by by a judgement
some sort of you know statement that we
make saying well this is the case or
this isn't the case or this is connected
to this or this has certain values and
this doesn't have value or this is more
valuable than that all of those things
are our judgments we are the judges we
are the critic to use the Greek term all
right curry taste we are the one who is
saying this is this is so and many of
the judgments that we make can be off
base and we don't always have arguments
that everybody could look at and say AHA
you made a logical error right here as
our basis for the judgments as a matter
of fact when it comes to most important
things it's not a process of
argumentation alone or even primarily
that leads us to saying oh yeah here's
here's how things actually stand so
judgments are things that have to
develop over time we actually do a
disservice in making people make their
judgments much earlier in processes than
they ought to so he says he's talking
about art and making judgments about art
he says always trust yourself and your
own feeling as opposed to argument
discussions or introductions of that
sort if it turns out that you're wrong
the natural growth of your inner life
will eventually guide you to
their insights it won't be the natural
growth of just acquiring more
information by looking up Wikipedia
articles or things like that it will be
you in a back-and-forth interaction with
more information and more experience and
probably talking to other people who
know something about these matters that
will eventually lead you to say oh I
understand it better now now I'm
actually equipped to make a judgement
that is growth so he says allow your
judgments their own silent undisturbed
development which like all progress must
must come from deep within and cannot be
forced or hastened everything Rilke says
is gestation and then birthing to let
each impression in each embryo of a
feeling come to completion entirely in
itself in the dark and the unsalables
stable in the unconscious beyond the
reach of one's own understanding and
then with deep humility and patience to
wait for the hour when a new clarity is
born this alone is what it means to live
as an artist understanding as is
creating so is he only talking about the
arts here no he's also talking about
philosophy he's also talking about
making judgments about where to put the
you know the new furniture that you
bought although hopefully that doesn't
take you quite so long he's talking
about psychology and understanding human
personal relationships he's talking
about a vast variety of things he's
saying it's okay
to allow your judgment to slowly develop
and the elements of your judgment or the
evidences to slowly develop as well and
to not have to like oversee the entire
process understanding every single thing
categorizing every single thing it's
okay to let it grow this is very
different than how we typically do
education isn't it where we you know
have a timetable for how everything
should happen and we often demand that
the students provide clarity and
evidence of every single step along the
way that might be a problem
and it could be that there are some
things for example coding where this
doesn't really apply to that although
you know insights about how to solve a
problem maybe it does apply to that but
there's other you know wide range of
things where this probably does apply
he's got another really wonderful
discussion about questions and answers
in letter 4 and this is really quite
brilliant this can apply not just to
young people as I put it out but to all
of us he says that you have to have
patience with everything unresolved in
your heart and try to love the questions
themselves as if they were locked rooms
or books written in a very foreign
language so you have to love the
questions
without knowing fully what they are this
requires a certain sort of faith the
certain sort of trust doesn't it and
this is very important
loving the questions like that he says
don't search for the answers no that's
not saying don't search for them ever
don't search for the answers why not
which could not be given to you now not
not that they couldn't actually be given
somebody can write them down and hand
them to you why can't they be given
because you would not be able to live
them so he says the point is to live
everything right now live the questions
live within the ambiguity of not having
an answer and eventually when an answer
comes you'll actually be in such a
condition when you can receive it he
says perhaps then someday far in the
future you will gradually without even
noticing it live your way into the
answer perhaps you carry within you the
possibility of creating and forming as
an especially blessed and pure way of
living train yourself for that but take
whatever comes with great trust take it
upon yourself and don't reject or heat
anything this is probably a great a bit
of advice not everything that
is puzzling us has to be resolved right
now a family member dies that doesn't
mean that you need to know what death is
a month from now so that you can get
over it and move on death may be an open
question you fall in love if you weren't
confused the first couple times you fell
in love if you didn't remain confused
later out in your life when you fell in
love
you probably didn't fall in love love
itself is a question that leads us to an
answer your vocation is an ongoing
question is it not so this is the advice
that he gives coppice when it comes to
love he talks about this in letter seven
and he has a lot of interesting things
to say one of the things that he tells
us is that says whoever looks seriously
will find that neither for death which
is difficult nor for difficult love has
any clarification any solution any hint
of a path then perceived and for both of
these tasks which we carry wrapped up
and hand down without opening there is
no general agreed-upon rule that can be
discovered does that mean that we're
totally at a loss nobody knows anything
about log or death or birth or any of
the existential zazz we you might call
them
no it means that we actually have a
world in which people are constantly
giving us all sorts of answers think of
all the songs out there about love that
you could draw upon and you know try to
use as a template for how to run your
life how do you know that any of them
are useful at all you respond to them
emotionally and you're like yeah and
that describes me I'm in that situation
the song only goes on for three and a
half minutes if it's a pop song is that
actually going to tell you how to live
beyond those three and a half minutes or
what to do the next day or how to live
week to week to week with that person it
doesn't tell you anything
we don't have answers that can be used
as complete blueprints we have to figure
it out ourselves we have to be patient
we have to sometimes experiment take
action see how things go we have to
communicate with the other person as
best as we can hoping that they can
actually understand us that is how we we
have to carry on these sorts of things
a little bit later in in letter 8 he
also talks about sadness and he brings
up anxiety as well
he says that that sadness and anxiety
are our times when the future is
entering into us and we have to allow
things to grow within us he says it's
important to be solitary and attentive
when one is sad because the seemingly
uneventful and motionless moment when
our future steps into us is so much
closer to life that other loud an
accidental point of time when it happens
to us as if from outside the quieter we
are the more patient and open we are in
our sadness the more deeply and serenely
the new presence can enter us the more
we can make it our own the more it
becomes our fate and later on when it
happens that is steps forth out of us to
other people we will feel related and
close to it in our innermost being so
this is what he's saying when it comes
to sadness when it comes to anxiety we
might think about other you know what we
call negative emotions as being
opportunities for us to exercise some
patience and look attentively at what
we're feeling and what it's connected to
and think about not how to solve it and
dispel it and make it go away
but what it means to us what it reveals
to us when it opens up for us what
future it holds for us
finally I'm going to end by bringing up
real cos very last letter to mr. Koppel
he talked about solitude and solitude is
one of the most central concepts of the
letters to a young poet and real cos
work in general solitude is what's
needed solitude Hines M kite being on
your own
developing this inner space that's
needed for for exercising patience and
and letting the time and growth
so he talks about cop as being in this
this place and says it must be immense
to silence and which sounds and
movements have room and if one thinks
that along with all this the presence of
the distance see also resounds perhaps
does the innermost note in this
prehistoric harmony then one can only
wish that you are trustingly
and patiently letting the Magnificent
solitude work upon you this solitude
which can no longer be erased from your
life which in everything that is in
store for you to experience and to do
will act as an anonymous influence
continuously and gently decisive so
that's another key aspect of this if we
develop solitude we'll be better able to
exhibit to to actuate this patience that
then allows things to grow which then we
can be part of and welcome
you